MARTHA MCSALLY: We have got to continue
on with their legacy and honor them
and there's no better, fitting way to do
that than this memorial here
at the University of Arizona.
[people clapping] [planes overhead] MCSALLY: As we go by this every single day
as those who are able to just, on their way
to school, or those of us who visit from time
to time or go out to do special run
for some event or whatever it is -
may we stop and we look at the names.
May we remember -may we remember and not
forget- the service, the sacrifice, the courage,
freedom is only one generation
away from losing it.
And we have people fighting as we speak on
the front lines in order to keep us free.
So let's have a fitting honor of their
memory and let's continue to forge and fight
for freedom and liberty and God
bless you all and God Bless America.
[people clapping] [American National Anthem]